welcome back to a20 special relativity
in this short section we want to
introduce a new notation for vectors and
you know if you look at previous uh
discussions this is actually not that
new we have seen that we need to treat
time and space in a consistent manner
and you have often
you know applied loans transformation
for example to a vector of time and the
next component of space now
you just want to do this with x y and z
here and not
treat
the y component then z component is zero
so we you know as a starting point you
can just simply say okay we have this
new four vector um
[Music]
and you know the zeroest component is
the time or time times the speed of
light and then the first component
second and third component are the
spatial component x y and z
now
i wrote a vector psi mu here
with the mu as being the upper index
i can also introduce psi with the lower
index and you see a little while in a
little while this is useful
where the zeroth component is not t but
minus r c t but minus c d
as a reminder for three vectors we you
know you learned about the dot product
which is just a multiplication of two
three vectors where all
vectors with n components where you
multiply you know the
same components of each vector and add
those results together
so the dot product of a vector a and the
vector b is the sum over all indices
um
for a i times b i
now for our four vector we do the very
same thing we just sum over all four
components
and we treat the vectors as a product of
the vector with the lower index and the
upper index
and you find here then we get
minus c t
c square t square plus x square y square
and z square
more generally this is for two vectors
of the same two of the same vectors more
generally for two different vectors we
can write
this in this in this way here
or in short you can divide define a new
notation in which you basically sum over
all
indices which are equal so here we have
an end upper and lower indices together
so you sum over
this case here where there's the same
index move for both vectors and one is
lower and one is upper
all right and we can you know continue
the introduction and just introduce a
few tools to work with those vectors
for example if you wanted to bring
you know the component mu
from the bottom to the top you can do
this with multiplying the vector with a
matrix and the matrix here
is also called a matrix
a metric
and simply what you have to do is
multiply the first component with a
minus one and the rest with one
you see this here on the diagonal all
other components of the o and what this
does you can check this if you want is
bringing
um the component the the index of the
vector from lower to upper one
all right
an interesting example is you know the
product of a for vector with itself and
we have already seen this because we saw
this as our invariant interval
um
here the four vector is the distance in
space and time between two events
so we looked at delta x i mu times delta
x mu and delta x mu is the difference
between event a and b
and so we have seen this already and
calculated the invariant and showed that
this
this
squared of a distance of two events is
actually invariant in the lawrence
transformation
but there's other examples for vectors
the first one we'll investigate some
more in the next six sections to come
is the energy momentum for vector where
we place in the first component the
energy
and in the
in the zeros component the energy and
then the first second and third
components the three vector of the
momentum
all right but there's others for example
the four potential where in the zeroth
component you have the potential the
electric potential and then the first
second and third component you have this
new field a
which is related to the magnetic and
electric field
so e m is not part of this course but uh
we'll come back to this in the in the
last week
um and uh and discuss the consequences
and
ideas a little bit more
all right but if you then you know look
at this the invariant four vector which
is a product of the energy momentum
vector you find that the first component
the energy square are minus the energy
square over c square plus the three
component vector of the momentum squared
and that's constant we can just here
name this
mass or minus mass square times c square
so if you
rewrite this you find this energy
momentum mass relation
e square is equal to p square c squared
plus m square c to the fourth power
and if you look at this four particles
of zero momentum in which case this
component here is zero you find the
equation e is equal to mz squared